[Musique]
sourire et même fou rire lors d'un
hommage national aux invalides cela
n'est pas possible que pour jean paul
belmondo lors d'une cérémonie solennelle
autant que populaire
sa famille ses innombrables amis du
cinéma du sport de la musique ou de la
télévision se sont réunis autour de son
cercueil drapé de tricolore
ainsi qu'en milliers d'anonymes venus
dire au revoir à bébel merci papy de
nous avoir donné tant de joie
merci d'avoir temps partagé sa
positivité
tu nous laisses rempli de ce bonheur
immense
on pense à toi on t'aime
et amuse-toi bien avec tes copains qui
tombent tant manqué permet d'offrir une
photo qui date du maquis du film
l'incorrigible
et elle est dédicacé par jean-paul voilà
et cela de mon coeur je l'aï merci
[Applaudissements]
six mois pour six mois va corriger le
coc jean paul et comme s'il a corrigé de
la télé ça tombe très bien
frédéric et vous êtes donc que dans une
tenue un peu spécial qui rappelle un des
rôles de belmondo dans le guignolo
effectivement le guignolo film
formidable et c'était effectivement le
costume idéal pour tout de suite faire
l'association
lorsqu'il prenait donc son hélicoptère
donc j'ai fait le choix hier tout de
suite rapidement de trouver un caleçon à
pois rouges d'un chapeau haut de forme
et puis les faire un chapeau l'artiste
pour son départ voilà et depuis le siège
passager d'une voiture rose avec des
étoiles vertes nous pourront crier que
finalement nous aimons la mer nous
aimons la montagne et nous aimons la
ville rien à [ __ ] pour vous belmondo
en tant qu'homme et en tant qu'acteur
est ce que c'est votre genre d'abord
c'est un très bel homme non mais on peut
le dire quand jean s'est remis de la
question
était présentée effectivement j'aurais
dit oui bon c'était pas mal question
il ya une scène où vincent karin viard
et vous même vous êtes totalement nue
gardons ça pour le non mais je n'en dis
pas plus d'ailleurs excusé moi c'est
rien à voir mais en parlant de tunnels
vous ressemblez curieusement rock aussi
enfin non non non non
bien d'ailleurs on voit pas du tout qui
tu parles non je vois
cet homme
[Applaudissements]
l'autobus n'est pas n'importe quoi ou
ses stars le
g10 autre beat
pour la création de rythme et boucles
mélodique selon des paramètres définis
par l'utilisateur général a été très
claire
autobus mais je comprends ce que je dis
c'est tout at-il besoin ça m'étonne pas
qu'il
a dit ça je ne vois que lui maintenant
qu'elle sait pas concentre toi sur le
visage oui oui oui
le problème c'est qu'il a un micro
devant regarder
le mignon le petit c'est là cette fois
vous devez réduire le sourire à un beau
petit à brommat cdi
c'est une fête des voisins
3 vous en dit vous en dit beaucoup la
mettant la même sans sa très belle scène
j'adore pleine scène marié pinsonneault
que j'ai trouvé hilarante un jeudi
vraiment en extérieur parce que quand
j'ai lu le scénario j'ai trouvé quelques
plages ou mêmes jeux mais j'imagine et
les jouets j'ai gardé du morceau il ya
énormément
saint-antonin-noble-val
parmi les curiosités locales le plus
vieil hôtel de ville de france la place
des halles et depuis quelques semaines
c'est macaron vert sur les vitrines des
commerçants
zone libre tous bienvenue avec ou sans
pass sanitaires emmanuel macron s'est
demandé si vous n'aviez pas peut-être pu
créer des phénomènes de rejet de la
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 donc
apparemment c'est un ressenti l'emmène
en septembre monsieur monsieur monsieur
vous êtes tordu vous êtes tordu le
président a commencé par dire qu'il
avait de l'estimé pour mon travail en
tant qu une grande scène est inique mon
travail en tant que grand scientifique
oui et là vous êtes tordu sur les
réseaux sociaux la bourgade est devenu
un symbole pour les antilles passe un
village d'irréductibles
capitale de la résistance
[Musique]
dans le sud ouest près de montauban et
ça ne s'invente pas à deux pas de saint
michel de vax saint-antonin résiste
encore et toujours à l'envahisseur
non pas les romains le pass sanitaire
façon nombreux variance que vous
conseillons aux français de se vacciner
tout simplement en tant que médecin
attendez c'est pas à moi de décider de
la politique vaccinale
votre conseil que je considère m laisser
parler répondre oui ou non vous laisse
par les professeurs alors ça suffit
alors vous me posez une question
laissez-moi répondit d'arrivée est
encore une minute de m'ennuyer mais
c'est infernal non mais c'est infernal
on s'arrête c'est fédéral ça suffit
oui pour d'un s'entend au cas où on
l'aurait pas trouvé eh bien je confie
dans la boîte à secrets qu'on leur sort
tu attends à ce moment là pour vacciner
la planète c'est le vaccin contre la
connerie
vous connaissez la réponse de roméo
juliette ou voir dans les années 80
un disque déjà non je sais temps c'était
en 1955 par la basse sur la prise de la
bastille été prise oui avec jeanne d'arc
occident ouais je connais j'expire je
connais tu avion a fait quelques soirées
ensemble
combien voit-on de personnages sur la
scène la célèbre fresque de léonard de
vinci du coup la salle pcc hé hé ning
alors et à les douze apôtres et jésus
est vraiment y a pas un serveur en pluie
mais je vais quand même dire 13
je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas
c'est terrible je sais pas je sais pas
mais c'est vraiment intéressant moi
shakespeare je le connais pas déjà j'ai
séché l'histoire-géo donc c'est
compliqué ensuite de sa jeu mais je mets
même pas le visage je ne sais pas de qui
on parle comment tu veux que je trouve
sa date de naissance ici j'ai
l'impression que dans la cène de léonard
de vinci avait un cerf aux morts mais en
fait je vois quelqu'un derrière et puis
si vous faites un groupe londonien mais
qu'il soit un flip est
jésus juge de
bon en vérité je voulais passer aux api
route à l'accusé me briser vous l'avez
vous vous avez deux derniers mon cher
l'oranje non faut dire avoir la caméra
leurs envies
rayons tous ensemble dans une salle de
cinéma plutôt que derrière notre écran
d'ordinateur
adieu paix tél